Welcome back to CNN this morning.
We are anticipating word
from law enforcement at any moment.
An update on this deadly mass
shooting in Monterey Port, California.
It appears that law enforcement
is approaching the microphone
as we speak right now.
At least nine people killed there.
Amara.
Yeah, let's listen in.
Good evening, everybody.
I'm Captain
Andrew Meyer from Sheriff's Homicide.
I'm going to have here to talk to you
about the mass
shooting incident that occurred here
in the city of Monterey Park.
This evening
or last night actually
at approximately 10:22 p.m..
Officers from the Monterey
Park Police Department
responded to a local business
in the 100 block of West Garvey Avenue
in the city of Monterey Park
regarding the shots fired call.
When officers arrived on scene,
they observed numerous individuals,
patrons of the location pouring
out of the location
screaming.
The officers made entry to the location
and located additional victims.
The Monterey Park Police Fire
Department responded to the scene
and treated the injured
and pronounced
ten of the victims deceased at the scene.
There were at least ten
additional victims
that were transported
to numerous local hospitals
and are listed in various conditions
from stable to critical.
The suspect
fled the scene and remains outstanding.
Anyone with information regarding
this incident,
we're asking them to call L.A.
Sheriff's Homicide at 323890.
5500.
Or if you're prefer to remain anonymous,
you can call Crime Stoppers at 800
2228477.
Homicide Bureau is working closely
with Chief Scott Weiss
and his agency
at the Monterey Park Police Department.
We're working with the California
Governor's Office of Emergency Services,
the Federal Bureau of Investigation, L.A.
Office
and numerous
other law enforcement agencies
With that,
I'll take a limited amount of questions.
If anybody
know, sir, as far as motive goes.
It's too early in the investigation
to know what the motive is.
A description of the officer?
No, sir.
Not at this time.
No, no
description on the suspect at this time.
All I can tell you
is that it was a firearm that was used
and no other information
on the part of the firearm right now.
The suspect is outstanding.
That's correct.
The indication of growing up,
the types of injuries seen around
this has been
going on
The location is there was ballroom.
It's like a ballroom dance.
Location,
location,
We're aware of a
an incident that occurred in Alhambra.
And we have investigators on scene
trying to determine
if there's a connection
between these two incidents.
Five
So we're
the investigators are working
every lead on this case.
Obviously,
we have all our resources here,
a limited amount of resources.
We have resources from various law
enforcement agencies.
We're reviewing
all surveillance video,
any surveillance video,
following all leads.
So we're
we're not going to leave anything
unturned
No, not at this time.
It's preliminary.
We will have more information
as more information
becomes available regarding the suspect.
We'll put that information
out to you guys.
Yes, sir.
We have ten
that are deceased at the scene.
And an additional,
we believe,
at least ten at local hospitals.
Everywhere, anywhere from critical
to stable.
I know you said no, no, there's no
connection there
as far as the suspect,
knowing any of the victims
is too early in the investigation.
We do not know that information
at this time.
That's yeah,
we don't know if it's targeted.
We don't know what the victims,
how old they are.
They are
no, we don't know how old they are.
I'll just take two more questions
and that's it.
We will update you guys further.
This is just a preliminary briefing.
We're going to have
a lot more information
to share with you
and in the future, in the coming hours.
At that second location,
we heard reports
that possibly civilians
have disarmed a possible suspect.
That's something that we're investigating
and we'll have additional information
about that.
We will look at every angle as far
as whether it's a hate crime or not.
It's just too early in the investigation
to know whether this incident
was a hate crime or not.
You know,
I'm going to
have the chief answer that question,
Chief. Sure.
The festival that occurred
Saturday also extended to Sunday.
Out of an abundance of caution
and reverence for the victims.
We are canceling the event
that's going to happen later today.
So the lunar festival here in Monterey
Park has been canceled
Just two more questions
about that.
Second,
No, not that I'm aware of.
I'm not sure if there's any injuries
or not.
We're still investigating.
And one other question
Within the next few hours.
Yeah. Thank you, everybody.
You say your name.
Sure.
Andrew Meyer,
M e y E.R..
All right.
Captain L.A.
Sheriff's Homicide.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
Okay, so we just heard an update
from the L.A.
County Sheriff's Department.
So the new numbers
and I hate to say numbers
because these are humans,
these are people who had lives.
Ten people dead in this
mass shooting in Monterey
Park, California.
This is just east of Los Angeles.
A suburb there.
We know that
there are ten additional victims,
according to police, who have been taken
to the hospital.
There
are injuries ranging
Just taking the range, some in stable,
some in critical condition.
And we know that there is a suspect,
the gunman who is now on the run.